donc l'effet remonte à la fin 2016
à l'époque mon mari a perdu son emploi
car l'entreprise c'est une boulangerie
industrielle où il travaillait à fermer
donc qui se retrouve licencié économique
du jour au lendemain plus ou moins en
tout cas et moi donc j'étais en arrêt
pathologique pour une grossesse à
l'époque qui malheureusement n'a pas
aboutiant
donc à l'époque
les ressources voilà des du trimestre
soignant et de l'année précédente donc
non
c'est une bonne nouvelle et à l'époque à
l'époque oui et à l'époque donc on était
tous les deux salariés lui a mon mari a
perdu son emploi moi j'étais en arrêt
pas tout donc à ce moment-là et donc
malheureusement il y a des délais
incompressibles quand on se retrouve
où licencié où on arrêt maladie il y a
des délais et de carence et des délais
administratifs qui ne sont pas
malheureusement
très très pertinent dans le sens où on
se retrouve foncièrement plusieurs
semaines sans rien voilà donc les
semaines là en tout cas on s'est
retrouvé pendant quatre semaines
vraiment sans rien du tout et on s'est
retrouvé dans la merde clairement et ce
qui est fou c'est vous dites que vous
pouvez donc vous avez volé de la
nourriture à l'époque c'était où c'était
quoi c'était en France
j'avais un caddie de course à roulettes
comme plein en nous et je le remplissais
et en fait je passais au caisses express
et je sortais que très peu de choses
et à quoi vous êtes fait attraper je me
suis fait attraper au bout de quelques
fois
aujourd'hui vous dites que vous allez
aujourd'hui la justice vous rattrape sur
cette et le problème c'est que la
justice est très longue donc là l'effet
remonte à fin 2016 le jugement a eu lieu
fin 2017 moi j'étais en train
d'accoucher à ce moment là ce que je
n'ai pas trop
détaillé chez Jordan que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs au passage
le problème c'est qu'en fait je n'ai pas
été avisé
du jugement parce qu'en fait un huissier
de justice est venu sonner chez moi un
jour sans doute pour me remettre ma
convocation et je n'étais pas là en tout
cas on était pas à la maison de ce
jour-là et j'avais a priori 3 mois pour
récupérer cette convocation à l'étude de
l'huissier sauf que chose que je ne
savais pas à ce moment-là et en fait
j'étais jugé par défaut et donc
aujourd'hui vous risquez quoi alors donc
j'ai pris six mois ferme parce que
j'étais une première fois donc par
défaut j'ai fait opposition à ce
jugement
condamnation enfin mon avis m'a voilà ma
convocation chez lui la justice et je
pense que ça ça a joué on va défaveur
clairement et donc là aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes passible de passer six mois
faire en prison bon en France en dessous
d'un an de prison ferme on sait qu'il y
a des aménagements quand même qui sont
mis en place pour que quand on travaille
qu'on a des enfants en tous les cas moi
j'ai été jugée et j'ai été condamné à 6
mois à faire j'ai fait opposition
jugement puisque j'étais jugé par défaut
sauf que en cadeau position on est jugé
par le même tribunal le même tribunal a
reprenon c'est la même peine en
opposition et là j'ai fait appel donc
j'attends la date d'appel qui devrait
avoir lieu dans rendre l'automne hiver
d'après mon avocat
lourde c'est c'est lourd c'est moi ferme
c'est vrai que c'est très étonnant mais
l'absence effectivement c'était notifié
d'ailleurs le fait que vous n'étiez pas
à l'audience à jouer contre vous parce
qu'on a estimé que vous vous dérobiez et
donc du coup la peine a été maximale
alors on dirait que je n'ai pas eu la
absolument vous êtes responsable c'était
votre faute entre guillemets donc on
appelle même si à six mois c'est vrai
que ce sera aménagé mais ça fait frémir
6 mois ferme pour avoir nourri ses
enfants en France
de nourriture
vous saurez
bientôt je pense enfin donc moi j'ai
mandat d'un avocat parce que c'est en
France comptait donc la région nous
vivions avant et celui-ci donc se
charger de me représenter en appel il a
fait la demande d'appel et il va me
représenter un appel donc d'après lui
puisqu'il y a les vacances judiciaires
durant l'été ça va être là
on espère que ça va s'arranger pour vous
quand même aujourd'hui ça va bien
qu'est-ce qu'il faut oui tout va très
bien aujourd'hui bah c'était fin 2016
depuis de loi de poulet sur les ponts
j'ai envie que l'eau coule sous les
ponts merci